Jim Kelly Shaw this is a man who writes
stories every single day sometimes
they're true sometimes they're not who
cares
he is the columnist for the Dallas
Morning News and around the horn
contributor good morning Tim good
morning Dan I assume you're calling
about the first-place maverick no talk
about the Cowboys here okay I'll check
back in with you on Lucca here coming up
in a moment because he did have a great
quote and I'm gonna bring it to your
attention all right Jerry Jones is not
helping the situation here when he makes
these comments does he realize in the
moment that he's not really helping the
situation by making these critical
comments he's very aware he's extremely
was okay it's not new to him he knows he
knows how his words are parsed after
every game and yeah I mean he's just
laying it out there the Belichick is a
genius and that that the coaching and
the fundamentals beat the beat the
Cowboys yesterday so he's he's got a
plan
what is the plan to execute it he's
starting to execute it well I mean I
think if the Cowboys don't get to the
NFC Championship game as we've talked
before it could be real hard for Jason
Garrett to stick around he's got a fine
record we've talked about it many times
yes nine and seven basically every year
but the two and three playoff record the
losses in big games no wins at all over
teams this year with winning records you
know they beat up their division
therefore no against their horrible
division and their two and five against
everybody else and they're probably
going to win the division but did I over
inflate them to him I I think they have
all the ingredients of being an NFC
title game caliber team but what is
missing here that that's that's what
gets to the coaching and whether they
take advantage of matchups whether they
see things that other teams don't a do
you ever watch them play a game go home
and look what the Cowboys figured out
about that that other team you see it
obviously constantly with New England
but even beyond
you see it with other teams they don't
have the only position in the team that
is to me averages their secondary but
salmon was supposed to be really good
DeMarcus Lawrence just got a hundred
million dollars you those linebackers
are supposed to be really good and that
should cover for the secondary a little
and it does sometimes but they start out
every game behind they start out every
game looking a little bit like they
don't know what they're doing is that
Jerry Jones calling you that is yeah
clearly okay you're gonna stay on with
me and you'll let that go to voicemail
yes I was trying to figure out this
strategy yesterday we make it seem like
the rain stopped and the wind stopped
when the Patriots got the ball for some
reason and it was only affecting the
Cowboys here but that whole game plan
here of going against New England what
did you make of it or did they have a
game plan you know I think the plan to
run the ball more was was a good idea
and that succeeded somewhat but yeah
they looked completely surprised to be
playing in the rain and to be playing
with a wet ball and you know where it
really showed up obviously it was on
special teams and I think Belichick had
seen what happened in the Detroit game
where Tony caller didn't field a kickoff
cleanly and it could have been a
disaster and so they did a couple of
those kicks that don't go to there to
the endzone and the Cowboys are all over
the map looking like the Keystone Cops
out there so you know it's just one team
knew what the weather was going to be
know it knows how to play in it and
Garrett's attitude has always kind of
will play anywhere anytime we just go
play football but that's that's kind of
a losing lament in a situation like this
what do you make of those tripping
penalties now that's that's weird and
then I'm never you know usually when
you've seen tripping it's a guy on the
ground or something sticking his foot
out and fairly obvious this is this is
Travis Frederick raising his knee about
three inches and catching a guy as he
goes by and I've never seen that called
I you know they can tell me that maybe
by
Lenard law is trippin but how many times
have you seen that I would that was that
was clearly not not not helpful to a
Cowboys cause I also didn't understand
when they were down inside the red zone
and it's third and eight I mean they
settled for the field goal and in the
moment I said I don't know if you're
gonna get back down here again I would
have to plays I was I would be geared up
for two plays and try to get the first
down
you know the defense was playing pretty
well the weather obviously an issue but
I didn't think they were gonna get this
opportunity again and I said I think
Troy Aikman said at the time as well
I'd be going for a touchdown your
thoughts on that I was in full agreement
on that I mean I think I could have gone
for it obviously I thought fourth and
seven you're playing the New England
Patriots well what are the Cowboys at
the end of the day on third downs I
think there were two for thirteen I mean
it's a really hard team to make that
play against but to your point there's a
little over six minutes to go you're
assuming you're going to stop them and
you know cutting the lead to four
doesn't do you much you're still gonna
need a touchdown at some point so I
don't think that was a great move I
don't think that was a killing
you know fatal move for the Cowboys
yesterday but but it wasn't it wasn't
exactly aggressive he's Tim Calhoun
Dallas Morning News columnist around the
horn contributor how big is the Luka
done chick fandom in Dallas well I mean
it's amazing I was at Friday night and
he just he had a normal game Friday he
had 37 and 14 and they won by 42 so it's
just kind of crazy we we thought
mistakenly dodge porzingis is going to
be one and one a there's only one one
and porzingis was getting better but i
mean he's as been pointed out many times
for a twenty-year-old he's putting up
numbers that only LeBron put up and and
he's beating most of those it's pretty
fascinating to watch Luca
was asked after the game that went
against Houston why the Dallas defense
is better this year and this is what he
had to say
[Music]
Dirk on defense which is tough that's a
great answer there but you know the Mavs
had to know what they were bad to see
something that nobody else was seeing
because you had Phoenix and Sacramento
who passed on him yeah so who is the
genius behind this you know I think
they'd looked at him for a long time and
then Donnie Nelson's history you know he
was the one who got Sharona smarsh
aloneness over here to Golden State
that's like almost 30 years ago now and
he was coached over there a lot so he
would have been on him early I think a
lot of people liked him but those those
first two that you mentioned they just
have it all we need centers one could
take 8 and then Bagley just ok you do
what you want to do you let this guy go
but teams did that with Jordan not to
compare Luca to Jerome yeah they always
did you know yeah we've got a good 6 5
guy we need a 7 footer ok you do what
you love to do now you know it's for
Atlanta sake I meet ray Young has been
great
yes he's not Luca great but he's been
really good so that's right isn't
terrible for them but yeah the Mavericks
to get him at five is is tremendous and
I was talking to Reggie Miller about
this Jalen Rose about this like we love
the news story and Luca is the news
story whereas the Greek freak is better
this year than last year
harden better this year than last year
LeBron has reinvented himself
the odds of Luca winning the MVP in your
opinion would be what they're still very
very long I mean those three guys that
you mentioned that all wanted are having
great years and we're still we're 16
games in so people are eventually going
to try to do something to get the
all out of his hands yeah it amazes me
the the way he still creates open
three-pointers is step back three and
people let him do it and maybe they
can't figure out how to not let him do
it but even even the way teams defend
hardened like they know what they can't
do there or try not to so the odds are
long but I think he's got a great shot
to finish in the top three as a twenty
year old which I think I saw has
happened I think somebody's been at the
top five three times ever so are you an
around the horn today I am on tomorrow
Dan would you like me to you know give
you some secret signal or I don't know
why either
I tell the audience to tune in because I
truly believe you I mean you're a
journalist and it just feels like you
disappoint my audience we've been doing
it for 17 years and will continue to
disappoint would you maybe put a sign
over your shoulder and what do you like
yeah sort of signage yeah like something
like that okay yeah okay well tune in
tomorrow
I'd say adjust your timing you don't
wear your tie do I have a word of tie
lately should I go back to the tie okay
plasticky wears ties every day yeah but
he doesn't get extra points for a tie
yeah you have a good winning records Oh
Isola wears ties does Frankie eyes does
he get does he get a lot of wins I don't
think so well it'd be nice if you gave
this audience a little acknowledgement I
mean we've been there for you thanks Tim
for taking time out today thank you
thank you Tim thank you that's Tim Couch
a Dallas Morning News and around the
horn for more Dan Patrick show tune in
to audience Channel 239 on DirecTV
stream for free on BR
five or download the Dan Patrick show
app
[Music]